infinity stones
how do you have these oh we actually got
a lot of those
yeah some of the guys use them as paper
weights welcome back everyone this is
going to be my new marvel loki video
explaining why the infinity stones don't
work anymore
loki's given away infinity stones like
their party favors who wants a new
paperweight for their desk
so marvel did just make the infinity
stones useless i'll explain
why they don't work and more about how
the timekeepers were actually able to do
that
so if you're brand new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos
i'm doing videos for all the episodes
and i'm doing a giveaway for disney plus
memberships and all my marvel videos all
you have to do to enter that is be a
subscriber
and let me know which of those infinity
stones you would take if you could get
them to work again
but careful for spoilers from everything
that happened in loki episode 1 if you
have not seen the episode yet
during the episode after almost having
to explain what a fish is to casey here
like i will gut you like a fish what's a
fish
casey is the name of the desk worker
here played by eugene cordero who was
also manning the front desk when they
first brought him in
sort of setting up the big tesseract
twist like oh what's this it seems
stupid
loki forces him to give the tesseract
back with the idea
that he'll just open another portal and
escape judgment it'll make a clean
getaway
but then they reveal what else he's got
in that little lost and found style
desk drawer and it shakes loki to his
very core
he's horrified like his whole world just
crumbles around him
this is really when he's meant to hit
rock bottom not only are there
countless priceless artifacts from the
marvel movies and from real life and
just in general there like the honus
wagner card that's worth over 3 million
dollars if you're a big baseball fan
they have all six infinity stones and in
most cases duplicates multiple copies of
infinity stones
like loki could theoretically make two
infinity gauntlets which normally would
make him
the ultimate power in the universe just
double fisting infinity gauntlets
but instead he winds up acknowledging
the tva is actually the greatest power
or might be the greatest power in the
universe because they're treating the
infinity stones as if they're completely
worthless
in fact the way casey talks about he
says oh we get these all the time
but the whole drawer itself is just
meant to show you how little they care
for what you would normally consider to
be extremely valuable in rare items
like if you or i found the hoeness
wagoner card sitting in the desk drawer
there
we'd just have a heart attack because
it's worth so much money loki has a
small heart attack looking at the
treasure chest of infinity stones
so after the episode aired a lot of
people saw this scene and yes it is
meant to be kind of funny because
they're playing on
the whole fish scene with casey it's
just meant to be a comedic scene in
general
but a lot of you on my episode 1 video
were commenting wondering if this was
marvel
trampling on black widows sacrifice and
iron man's sacrifice in avengers endgame
like if marvel is saying the infinity
stones don't matter anymore
what did black widow die for what did
iron man die for
so just to clear this up you're at least
half right there marvel is using this
scene to make loki feel very small and
insignificant taking the wind out of his
sails
and yes they are using it in a meadow
way to say that the infinity stones
won't be a thing anymore
in marvel phase 4 movies like we spent
10 plus years during the infinity saga
movies treating the infinity stones
as if they were the most important thing
in existence this big mcguffin across
22 plus films now kevin feige and the
marvel movies want to move on to the
next big thing move past the infinity
stones and also say that no
marvel villains won't be traveling back
in time again repeating the thanos plot
repeating the avengers plot and just
trying to assemble another infinity
gauntlet and just do the exact same
thing over and over again
so they needed some way to logically
explain how that was not possible
anymore and sort of wink from behind the
camera and tell fans
no we're not going to go back to these
in a big way anytime soon but here's the
big twist with the tva and the
timekeepers
the way the tva is able to make it seem
like these infinity stones don't work
anymore
isn't because they're more powerful than
the infinity stones the infinity stones
themselves haven't changed fundamentally
they're still crazy powerful
this is where we get into a lot of the
smoke and mirrors aspect behind the
timekeepers like wizard of oz style
who's really behind the curtain here
what's really going on
yes the timekeepers do have advanced
control of time travel and time
manipulation making
it seem as if they're powerful as gods
but they're not actual gods not in the
way the one above
all in the marvel universe is the true
god or even in the way that thor is a
lesser god in the mcu
there was a joke about this earlier in
the episode when loki is on trial
asking to speak to the time keepers gods
to gods and judge renslayer just says
they're far too busy to meet with him
but that was kind of a misdirect it was
more foreshadowing for the wizard of oz
style reveal
dark twist time keepers are not gods so
the way that the tva is able to make it
seem like they could cancel the infinity
stones power or suppress them
is actually because the time keeper
citadel here exists in its own separate
pocket dimension
outside the normal flow of time what you
would consider the normal multiverse
so when you say beings like the schuma
goreth the many angled ones were born in
the void before
the existence of the universe before the
big bang before the multiverse was
created
the timekeeper citadel exists in a space
like this outside of what you would
consider the normal multiverse which is
how they're protected from changes in
the timeline
that's why nobody in this place got
snapped when thanos assembled the
infinity gauntlet in infinity war
that's how it's so easy for them to make
decisions like this like no we'll let
half of all life get snapped
and then we won't arrest the avengers
because we want them to go back in time
and bring everyone back and the big
thing with the infinity stones is that
they
only work inside the universe where they
were created
so in this destroyer you have infinity
stones from a bunch of different
universes
and that's why they don't work like loki
could theoretically
use some of these infinity stones to
make an amalgam infinity gauntlet
travel back into the main marvel
universe where he came from we'll call
that the universe that loki 616 came
from
even though technically the mcu is
supposed to be a different universe
per marvel phase 1 phase 2 and phase 3
but if he did that
the only infinity stone that would work
would be the tesseract because that's
where he stole
this tesseract from all these other
infinity stones came from other
universes so they'd be completely
worthless
but if it still wasn't clear why there
are so many infinity stones in this
drawer here it's just because the idea
you have all these nexus events being
created these branch timelines the tva
goes in
arrests whoever created the nexus event
then takes the infinity stone that they
use to do that
and throws it in a desk drawer so you
just have a bunch of them accumulating
over time
so even though the marvel movies going
forward aren't gonna use the infinity
stones the same way ever again as big
plot devices
and they're turning them kind of into
jokes here like these are just
completely ridiculous things sitting in
a desk drawer
the reason why this scene doesn't
completely throw iron man and black
widow's desk under the bus
is just because of the idea that they
only work in their original universes so
they're not taking away the power of the
infinity stones they've just shifted
them to another reality where
they don't work anymore if you took all
these individual infinity stones back to
where they got them from
then they would work again but i think
the idea is that a lot of these were
collected from
branch timelines nexus events that
created new branch timelines
that they then close down so you could
not take these back to the universes
that they came from anymore because they
don't exist
and in case it's been a hot minute since
you've re-watched avengers end game
thanos actually said that he atomized
the infinity stones after he traveled to
his garden planet to prevent anyone from
using them again
so he didn't fully destroy them because
that's impossible he merely changed
their state to the level of atoms so
they're just imperceptible
and ant-man could try to go around and
collect every single atom
of the different stones and reconstitute
them that way but it would take a
billion years to do that
but per the rules that the ancient one
explained to the hulk that's how the
normal flow of time
in the main marvel universe continues on
going forward like it's supposed to for
all the regular avengers characters
the infinity stones are supposed to help
control the flow of time
and at the end of the movie captain
america returns all the ones that they
stole
back to where they came from eliminating
those other potential nexus events they
created along the way like he says i'll
clip all the branches bruce talking to
the hulk
also for those of you asking about why
old man captain america did not get
arrested
because he went back to live with peggy
carter in 1942 creating another
separate branch timeline in another
nexus event the reason why the tva
probably didn't arrest him is
probably for the same reason judge
renslayer claims that the avengers
all were not arrested probably because
the timekeepers
claimed captain america was supposed to
do what he did
supposed to travel back in time to be
with peggy carter and then come back to
the main timeline
and if that seems kind of suspect like
why would they want him to do that
and break the rules in that way and not
arrest him but not want loki to do what
he just did at the beginning of episode
one
it just plays into the idea that
something is wrong with the timekeeper
something is sinister
it's supposed to feel like they're not
really good characters
also for those of you asking about the
peggy carter cameo scene that
a lot of people were discussing on
social media no i do not think that this
person in the background of the scene is
supposed to be peggy carter
there is a woman being arrested by the
tva in the background when loki is
trying to escape who's dressed in a blue
outfit with a haircut
that seems similar to peggy carter it's
not the same outfit that peggy carter
was wearing like this is a completely
different outfit
but just because she looks kind of
similar and she's kind of blurry and you
can't see her face really
people wondered if it was peggy carter i
think this is just meant to be a random
person in the background
continuing to illustrate the tva arrests
all kinds of people from different eras
all over the place
all the time like the douchebag from
goldman sachs
getting vaporized i think if this were
supposed to be peggy carter the creators
of the tv show the cast
and hayley atwell herself would be
talking about it by now
the best example of something like this
is mark hamill's cameo scene on the
mandalorian season 2
the minute the mandalorian season 2
finale was released mark hamill started
tweeting
all kinds of funny references to his
cameo scene without completely giving
away spoilers like have you seen
anything good today
anybody watching any good tv episodes so
had this have actually been
peggy carter you would have seen a bunch
of official marvel people talking about
it
and even though they did get a little
confusing with the way they talk about
the one single sacred timeline concept
there is still a multiverse like they've
sort of wound
the what they consider to be the sacred
multiverse into a single timeline the
sacred timeline
it's just that the timekeepers have the
tva hunters eliminate branch timelines
that they deem
bad so there are other realities as part
of this single sacred timeline all kind
of wound together
in a single timeline but they'll
continue to explore this and explain how
this works in episode 2
in future episodes so if it feels like
it's still kind of confusing now don't
worry
they'll continue to explain stuff
through future episodes there are also a
lot of you asking about dr strange's 14
million possibilities when he was using
the time stone during infinity war the
whole idea being that he found the one
timeline where they were able to beat
thanos and that involved their time
travel plot so the funny thing that
judge renslayer is talking about here
like the avengers were supposed to go
back in time that's why they weren't
arrested
the idea is is that the avengers had
actually done something different tried
some different plan in those 14 million
they would have created another nexus
event creating another branch timeline
that the timekeepers did not want to
exist
in the tva would then have stepped in to
shut it down so like i said tom
hiddleston did confirm the series would
continue to explore the whole wizard of
oz aspect of this like the darker
implications
of this idea that the time keepers deem
what is sacred and what is not sacred
who's really behind the curtain who's
really pulling the strings here because
they definitely do not seem like good
people
and just because they are moving past
the infinity stones as big plot devices
in marvel phase four
doesn't mean that they won't ever
reference them again so for instance we
have the eternals movie coming up later
this year
and yet the idea that the celestials in
the early history of the mcu
would go around the universe gardening
things growing experimenting on things
creating the eternals creating the
deviants and when they were doing that
they would use
infinity stones to aid them in their
tasks like you have issan the searcher
using the power stone
to cleanse this planet that he deemed
the experiment it failed on okay time to
start over again we'll just
wipe the slate clean and try over so
we'll probably see some references to
the infinity stones again during the
eternals movie when they're explaining
the backstory the creation of the
celestials and the creation of the
eternals
just an example of how even though
they're not going to be a really big
deal going forward the infinity stones
themselves are still a big deal
technically one of the very few replicas
that i allowed myself to buy was a
full-size replica of the infinity
gauntlet after infinity war came out
although it took so long for them to
make that that i actually didn't receive
it until after avengers end game came
out in theaters
my full loki episode 2 video is gonna
post wednesday just like normal there's
a special new spider-man teaser that was
released sometime recently i might do a
video for that tomorrow make sure you
have alerts enabled for my channel so
you don't miss any of the episodes
and congratulations just some guy with a
mustache you're the giveaway winner for
my last big marvel video please email me
on the about page of my channel so i can
get your contact details
everyone click here for my full loki
episode 1 video
and click here for my loki episode 2
trailer video thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe and i'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]
you